[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank him job
whereas I first think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death where two brothers answer your
questions give you devious advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon how you doing
John I'm doing well we're in the same
place right now we're both in Missoula
Montana Hank right now is opening up one
of the three hundred seventy eight
pieces of peanut butter taffy we
received here at the Missoula offices
thank you person who sent that Hank you
have a name Oh salty wrote on the
package I don't know who Chantelle well
we're very grateful for it and if you
could just turn the microphone away and
also leave the room because that is the
loudest chewing noise I have ever heard
in my entire life where's really cherry
oh my god I just found out a new fear
that I have or a new thing that causes
me anxiety and it is the sound of my
brother chewing loudly so I'm doing well
Hank for the last three weeks we've been
on tour together and I have been
engaging in an experiment I don't know
if you've known about this but I've been
engaging in an experiment called how
poor does a hotel bathtub have to be for
me not to want to take a bath in it what
so what are the qualities of a tub we'll
be looking for in a tub
there's cleanliness obviously that's
probably at the top of the list for me
and then there's depth and width and
length all of which are important and of
course in the opinion of America's
hotels are important in that you know
more of them means more water wasted so
they try to absolutely minimize the
depth length and height of a bathtub
which has meant that I've taken a lot of
baths where I was like I feel like a big
person in a tiny tiny bathtub girl two
year-old girls up in a little ball in
the fetal position on your side just
being like how do I get more of my body
into the water or just barely get my
knees wet or my shoulders wet never both
it occurs to me that this may be why I
don't take baths because this is what my
bath tubs have always been like in my
homes
oh no that's one of the first things
that I mean I gotta get my
knees and my shoulders and at the same
time oh well then what is the point of
going on living yeah okay maybe it maybe
I don't like baths because I've never
had a true bath oh my god I imagine
being 37 years old and discovering for
the first time ever how good I've been
am happy hot tubs are not bad hot tubs
are filthy hot tubs are taking baths
with bunch of people do you know they'll
take a bath together is basically what
that mean you say when you say let's go
do the hot tub
what a weird idea let's all go take a
bath together but with the pants on
hopefully oh god I don't want to talk
about hot tubs it's funny for somebody
who really loves bad so I really hate
hot tubs I think that's understandable
because like the bathwater you make it
go away this is my main problem with
baths is that I feel like I'm in but
water because my butts in the same water
that it's like hot but water mm-hmm as
my butts yeah so but it in a hot tub
it's like ancient butt water it's like
yeah but water of potentially thousands
of people and diff on different days
yeah that's what I kind of feel about
the hotel bathtub but so far it hasn't
deterred me and as you know I brought
bath salts and bath bombs do you know
this and so almost every night after the
show I'm enjoying some bath salts and
bath bombs before we get to the
questions from our listeners we just
have to mention one thing really quickly
which is that very soon after this
podcast is uploaded Hank and I will be
almost all the tour is sold out except
for San Francisco where Hank and I are
going to be on Halloween it's going to
be a Halloween spectacular there's going
to be a costume contest meg and I are
going to be extensively costumed and
maybe costume changes my Halloween
costume for the San Francisco show is so
freakin good I don't know what it is
it's so good I don't want to brag it's
phenomenal so if you want to get tickets
to see us in San Francisco you can do
that at Turtles all the way down
book.com but you can't get tickets to
see us anywhere else sorry the way a
pleasant Pleasanton yeah also in the San
Francisco area there are also tickets
available for that on November 1st yeah
on November 1st or possibly October 30th
I think it's November first but I could
be wrong
who knows point being we're looking
forward to the last week of
tor yeah also looking forward to being
back home with our families the nice
thing about catching the tail end of the
tour is that we're good now we've got it
we've got it sewn up we know or doing I
all I know where all my laugh lines are
and and I like I might throw a new one
and to see how it goes and like as the
tour goes I'm like I know are all the
best I know how to do a best we're
better I wouldn't say who were good yet
um we put together like a pretty stellar
experience honestly like I walk out of
that show and I'm like we did like it
was tight there was a lot of ups and
downs uh hey I'm not just trying to sell
tickets here but I am trying to sell
tickets in addition to other things I
love I love the confidence of my brother
and also wish for it let's answer some
questions from our listeners thank this
question comes from Matt who writes Dear
John and Hank why does the am/pm change
at 12 instead of one this makes no sense
step over the door Matt no I step over
the doormat why don't you just step on
the doormat that's what the doormats
form I would step on it yeah I don't
care about the bottom of my shoes
touching other people's bottom to their
shoes no not like a hot tub situation no
it's really kind of the opposite of a
hot tub situation like I have like three
layers of protection between me and the
doorman the doorman I'm not getting in
my toes and even if it does like what do
I care what my feet are experiencing
they're gross anyway I'm not gonna put
them on my mouth Oh unless you're a baby
no you have to cut that Nick Nick's in
the room for the first time ever Nick's
in the room so now when I say we have to
cut that Nick I'm actually speaking to
Nick yeah
Nick we have to cut that keep it keep
all of this all right so I looked this
up and then I forgot yeah right which
I've done a many different times so it
just basically like a.m. means before
noon and PM means after noon and so or
yeah yep yep you so with a switch from
p.m. to a.m. happens yeah when it
becomes before noon yeah right and so it
is before it is after midnight and
before noon at 12:01 and the important
thing to note yeah
is that in everywhere else mm-hmm that's
not midnight it's it is it's midnight
but it's not 12 it's zero right yeah oh
yeah they always talk about Oh 800 hours
or zero dark thirty Oh zero dark thirty
being the 30 minutes after midnight zero
daytime 30 I'm not I'm gonna level with
you Hank I'm not in the military the
zero day 30 sir doesn't sound like a
thing that's happened I think it's
called zero dark thirty and zero bright
thirty that's my guess 0:30 yeah so just
like hey everybody we're gonna meet for
the big raid at zero bright thirty zero
dark thirty is a very late or very early
time of day what is the time between
midnight and Dawn apparently according
to the online slang dictionary calm okay
great great then the poor before half an
hour past midnight that seems more like
it zero dark thirty s half an hour past
midnight which but what's half an hour
past noon is it just 12:30 that's what
it is it's 12:30 because there's not a
third I use a 24-hour calendar so that's
that's what it is happily right yeah
it's a calendar Hank a 24-hour wall
calendar what do you have the new ID new
Apple eye calendar yeah it's great I get
my I actually make that mistake
frequently when I'm setting my alarm
because we've had to get up at weird
hours on this tour and I always hit
calendar and then I'm like where's my
alarm clock so actually yes that is true
this question comes from it's your turn
to ask a question but it goes from our
listener Greta who asks dear Hank and
John my best friend and I have our first
class of the day together and she is a
forgetful person I am this person by the
way almost every day she asks me for a
pen to borrow I can't I don't know why I
never brought pens to school but I am
this person which is fine with me but
then throughout the class she chews on
it no I am NOT this person note your
friend Greta is no longer your friend
Greta this person is not your friend
Greta I think I've done this before imma
shoot on someone else's pen oh well I am
an inveterate pen - or I was sure I was
in
College in high school of course I no
longer own overused pens except sharpies
hashtag sponsored this whole tour by the
way I've been signing with the Sharpie
sent me ninety-six free sharpies because
I guess they don't listen to the pod and
they'll hold the whole tour I've been
signing with my green sharpies that say
John Green's number one marker and in
almost every city a book seller is like
did you get personalized sharpies made
and I'm like I'm not sure if it makes it
better or worse that I got personalized
Sharpe and sent to me yeah like like
yeah none asked for personalized
sharpies I didn't ask for them in so
many words but I did at reply sharpie
and just let them know that I was a big
customer you are a big customer so it's
a credit goes on to say uh what am I
supposed to do when she gives me the pen
back take the slobber pen or just let
her keep it yeah let her keep it she is
now claimed she might as well feed on it
like this is her pen now how you claim
ownership over your pens I have a drawer
and I just pee in there a little every
morning Hank takes the same approach to
ownership as dogs do I mean how else do
you mark your turf man it's it's legal
it's like blockchain it's better than
blockchain peeing on stuff Greta
here's the answer to your question when
the person hands you back the chewed pen
you look them dead in the eye and you
say I would like you to keep that pen
and remember to bring it back tomorrow
and remember to bring it more every day
for the rest of class or yeah
Greta buys for one dollar and fifty
cents you know of like 25 pens and then
just has like a pen supply for for her
friend and just like says like you know
hey we're buds and like and I just wanna
keep this in my bag and this is already
earmarked and I've lost these pens right
and if the pay that the friend gives the
pen back you say you keep it and if
they're like oh I insist that you take
this the thing that I might as well have
peed on you just throw it like bring a
ziploc glaze it in there like it's in
evidence
in the trash as a way of making it clear
you bring a ziplock and you take the pen
from your front of you place it in the
ziplock and then you write out a little
tag like the date and you place that and
you zip it up right in front of her and
he or him I don't know you didn't
mention the gender of this person then
when they go to visit you in your dorm
room eventually you have this collection
of all the signs of all the sides like a
sports room where they have like every
one of the home runs from that year just
like tacking tacked up but instead it's
alava a sports room a locker room I
think is the place that was thinking
know what's called a sports room you
know how sometimes people like when
their baby gets the first haircut they
keep a keep a lock of the hair from the
first haircut
I don't know how Orrin had a haircut
yeah no no no so we did that but one
time I was visiting somebody I'm not
going to name them for reasons that will
become obvious and I went into the
bathroom and I noticed that they had a
huge collection of locks of hair and I
found out that they had saved a lock of
hair from every haircut their child had
ever gotten until the age of 18 were
they like separately bagged or were they
just like in a pot no they were framed
Oh each individual one each individual
one with a date below the frame and I
always like until eight kids so I came
outside and now it's like hey Ben it's a
public space the guest bathroom i what
it wasn't like the only bathroom in the
home it was the guest bathroom and so
it's like and they also had a really
good art collection so I thought maybe
like maybe it's art maybe it's heart and
I went in so I was like hey who made the
piece of the with the hair we'd set with
is art and they said oh no that's our
kids hair I was like oh yeah no totally
targets that's normal that's like my
friend Greta has a pen collection of
chewed pens it's very similar John do
you wanna know the most embarrassing
thing about me yeah all right so you
guys didn't hear the most embarrassing
things because I decided it was too
embarrassing for the pod I made
kind of a team decision actually not
because Hank was concerned about how
embarrassing was but because it's so
embarrassing for me as somebody who
loves Hank so it's one of those things
we're like sometimes you need somebody
to come in and care about you enough to
say no so instead I'm just gonna tell
you the second most embarrassing thing
about Hank Oh melter a little bit of
context so you can understand how
embarrassing the thing that you'll never
hear about is the second most
embarrassing thing about Hank is that
for about 18 months he faked a British
accent it's not entirely true it's
entirely true it was like a Canadian
British accent but it was like if a
British person moved to Minnesota when
they turned 7 he only spoke in that
accent and we would be like Hank where
we notice like it doesn't you don't
sound like yourself and he'd be like but
but whatever do you mean
[Laughter]
comes from Thomas and you'll never guess
why I wanted to ask it as I read it Dear
John I think I pre-ordered John's new
book with the goal of giving it to my
girlfriend for Christmas she doesn't
usually read that much but she's a huge
fan of your book so I decided to grab a
signed edition as soon as I could
I normally have a hard time picking out
gifts for her which is why I decided to
buy her a gift so early this year fast
forwarded this morning when the book
arrives in my mailbox I decided to
message one of her friends to try and
covertly dissuade her from buying
herself a copy and her friend told me
that my girlfriend just this morning
went out to the local bookstore and got
a copy of turtles all the way down but
she didn't buy it for herself she got it
to give me Christmas so now I know that
we're both got each other the same thing
for Christmas my question is should I
get her something different or is it ok
to exchange copies of the exact same
book it is not just ok it is adorable
Thomas you fail to notice how incredibly
cute this is
it'll be like get the baby like wow this
feels familiar continue PS is it okay to
read a book that you're planning on
giving as a gift
that's the better question cuz
absolutely yes exchange the gift and
pretend like you didn't know and it'll
be cute yeah ideally pretend that you
didn't know like sometimes when you're
some I think some relationship dynamics
dictate that you have to eventually
reveal right new but some relationship
dynamics don't I don't know how it works
for you Thomas but is it okay to read a
book that you're planning on giving us a
gift I think yes as long as you read it
very gently read it gently and maybe
also say I read this right and I love
that and I'd like to talk to you about I
hope you wanted by the way Thomas that
was presumptuous if I read this and I
loved it it was perfect and it says got
a star review from the Library Journal
of children I found myself agreeing with
the Guardian that it might be Agnew
classic right yeah but I think it's okay
to read a book what I don't think is
okay to read a book that you give as a
gift and I've had someone do this for me
before and they thought it was like
sweet and romantic and I thought it was
a little bit presumptuous was to read
the book before giving it to me and to
highlight their favorite passages hmm
it's kind of sweet in a way but in
another way it affects my read in a way
that I don't necessarily like I don't
know that's interesting I think that
that's a little bit like a mixtape to me
so you're not just giving the book now
you're saying like this is about me in
some way so like that this book I'm
giving you this book and it's something
that I've kind of curated and created
for you right I guess maybe it's just
that this breakup didn't go that well
and now I'm biased by that experience
yeah I think I think that there are both
both good and bad things to that and I
think that that would be that is sort of
to me more acceptable if it's something
I give us a classic or if it's like
Turtles all the way down according to
the Guardian new modern classic yeah
yeah this next question yeah is
available at bookstores everywhere by
the way absolutely everywhere you know I
went to I went to the the bookstore and
the airport in Minneapolis yeah and it
wasn't in like front display and I was
like I like went to the people and I was
like where's turtle all the way down
there like well it's in best
and why and I was like well this it's
two places it should be out like I
should have to trip over them to get out
of this door come on Dan Brown's all up
in this business where's my brother and
and then the person who I talked to was
like great show last night by the way
she got me to sign the guestbook and she
was done she was a fan very nice person
I probably didn't need to get like hard
charged about Turtles all the way down
to placement which I suspect probably
also wasn't her call really her call
this next question it comes from Paige
who asks dear Hank and John I have a
deep burning question that has plagued
me why have we not evolved to withstand
a greater amount of heat in our bodies
specifically our mouths the planet's
climate is changing and has been for
millions of years so shouldn't I be able
to drink a pumpkin spice latte at 140
degrees Fahrenheit without burning my
taste buds off ow
Paige it sounds like Paige's having a
moment right here
yeah email us during it yeah well I mean
here's my suspicion and correct me if
I'm wrong Hank evolution pretty slow and
also it tends to focus on like major
survival concerns right pumpkin spice
lattes pretty new also not a major
survival concern no maybe in the future
it's just gonna be it's like though the
way that PSL graph has been going it
does seem like in a number of like maybe
two or three years that will be all of
food in the fall I didn't know what the
PSL graph was but then I figured it out
the context it's put the pumpkin spice
latte gruff latte graph graph plot a
graph the mother of God
it's the pumpkin spice latte graph I
mean that's the new she sells seashells
by the seashore
goodness gracious yeah but I know we
actually are better at eating hot food
like our mouths are better at handling
heat them like our hands are really than
other skin places Oh which is probably
an evolutionary thing because if it's
good enough for the hands it's
definitely good enough for the mouth
yeah that's part of it and also like
when we started cooking food like you
put a lot of hot
stuff in your mouth and you don't want
that to be a source of like infection so
mouth cells grow back very fast so when
you burn your mouth heals much faster
than if you burn your skin so mm-hmm
a little something there I'm not
concerned about okay I have a question I
have a related question about this it's
about two ATAR okay it's only
tangentially related have you ever given
it to Atari pumpkin spice latte because
that sounds interesting
not yet I mean but I've so many
experiments are still waiting to be done
on the worlds tuatara here's my question
to Atari one of the oldest terrestrial
vertebrates still around their body
forms haven't changed much in 150
million years but they have this
incredibly fast rate of molecular
evolution like the what's they mutate a
lot they they're their cells mutate a
lot which makes some people think that
maybe cells used to mutate a lot more
than they do now but makes other people
not think that here's my question since
they have this really high metabolic
evolution rate or since they have this
higher since they have this really high
molecular evolution rate compared to
most newer animals why haven't their
bodies changed I mean so you can kind of
think of this a little bit like if you
get to the bottom of a well you might
not be the deepest you can get in the
well but to get to another place to get
deeper you have to get all the way back
out of the well and go down a different
hole so to ATAR might have sort of
gotten to as good as they can get
without sort of like starting over a lot
right okay so like like it definitely
like they are pretty close to as good as
they can get for for you know the the
strategies that they're using right but
they're not great I have to say at most
things yeah like two ATAR are really
good at living for a long time and it
hanging around on earth for a hundred
fifty million years and though literally
the only two things they're really good
at the other thing is like evolution is
spurred by a lot of different things and
like like like differentiation is
spurred by a lot of different things and
that can be like you need evolutionary
pressure so if there isn't a lot of
evolutionary pressure
forcing them to adapt then they probably
might not adapt very much like they
might just sort of like keep all of the
things that are working for them working
and that's the main goal of being a
tuatara and also you don't because
tuatara are sort of they were just in
one place just on the mainland of New
Zealand and surrounding Islands then you
know like there wasn't a lot of it
wasn't a lot of separation of the
species to let them sort of explore
different paths thanks Hank that's
helpful and also helpful to readers of
turtles all the way down my new I want
to learn more about tuatara Turtles all
the way down available in two different
places at the Minneapolis bookstore and
at the airport which reminds me that
this podcast is brought to you by John
Green's new book turtles all the way
down it's the last week Hank I will make
us flog Turtles all the way down
romantically on the pod yeah we got a
little start doing pod con right after
that it's gonna be a freaking great time
the agendas on the website now sorry
that's not a sponsor that's for next
week vodka are a great place for my new
book it's very confusing this this
podcast is also brought to you by my
fake Minnesotan British accent why I'm
so glad the internet didn't exist and
there are no videos of that oh that's a
great point Hank it could be so much
worse because I'm sure as bad as I
remember it being I'm sure it was worse
in real life today's podcast is also
brought to you by our San Francisco show
God and our pleasant didn't show actual
things that are actually happened that
we would love to see you people from
California at and finally this podcast
is brought to you by slobber pen
evidence bags they're disciplic bags but
they're available and you can put your
slobber pins in them and nail them to
the wall and have a Hall of Fame slobber
pens or just or just do that if people
like they'll come to your bathroom and
be like why are there a bunch of pens
and Ziploc bags in your bathroom and
you'll be like it's art this next
question comes from Kyle who writes dear
green brothers I always love it when you
shill for yourselves on the pause this
is true question Hank you highlighted it
it helps me to keep up with all the
amazing new things you're both doing
what
or service are you making or providing
but you haven't shield for on the pod
I'd like to hereby I'd love to hear
about it only for a while Kyle I mean
it's a great sign off yeah
also Kyle knows how to get this question
on the Todd I know yeah hey by the way
could you like anybody wants to write in
a question be like this is your chance
to talk about a thing you need to tell
people about there is something what
pizza miss oh it's pizza miss the most
magical time of the year god every year
for two weeks Hank and I make a video
every weekday back and forth to each
other like we did back in 2007 and it's
a celebration of love and brotherhood
and also ecommerce you could go to
dftba.com and there's a bunch of Pizza
miss merch that's only available during
pizza miss and after this will never be
available again every year there's
different Pizza miss stuff this year
we've got lots of amazing pizza maasai
tumble at dftba.com so there you go Kyle
just when you thought we couldn't
self-heal anymore it turned out and I
found yet another level this next
question comes from Ann jolly who asks
dear Hank and John I'm in a public
health class in my college right now and
we recently learned about the influence
of vaccines and apparently they're made
inside of chicken eggs I was shocked but
willing to go along until my professor
asked us what would happen during an
apocalypse what if a flu pandemic broke
out during the apocalypse would we try
to make a vaccine is there a supply of
emergency chickens for this situation
concerned about our world's supply of
emergency chickens among other things
and jolly I don't think that's our
biggest concern UPS like the flu
pandemic after the apocalypse I'm like
no no this is a legitimate concern
because once once all the I think about
this a lot but like once all of it like
primary health facilities sort of break
apart and vaccines are part of that but
there's lots of other things as well
like a sanitation especially yep yeah
there will be like huge global pandemics
that are a big problem in fact we
already see this to an extent in places
where there's a big breakdown of the
social and political order like in Yemen
right now there's probably in in the end
the cholera outbreak in Yemen will
probably be the largest cholera outbreak
in
many decades and it's not because we
don't have a vaccine for cholera we do
it's not because cholera isn't
preventable it is it's because we aren't
using you know because we can't get in
there to do all the things we need to do
and also that like we as a global
community have chosen not to devote the
resources that would be necessary to do
the things that we would have to do so I
am actually worried about that I think
that's what yeah yeah I mean my concern
isn't the supply of chickens I think
that will probably keep chickens around
yeah yeah it turns out that they're not
hard to maintain though the way that
we're currently doing it maybe I am
concerned that like you don't just need
a chicken and an egg to make a vaccine
you need a laboratory and you need yeah
production facilities and those are the
things that I'm more worried about that
you need electricity you need running
water yeah do you need a lot of things
that we might struggle to have here's
the thing though and Jolley if things
start to break down like that we're
going so far down like things are gonna
get so bad that I think Hanks probably
write that on the list of like on the
list of like worries that's the thing
about doomsday prepping on Jolley you
can only do so much of it because the
truth is it's gonna be awful and even if
you live it's gonna suck thanks for
listening so glad I pulled that question
out John
I don't really say I mean like I don't
have anything else to say there yeah it
would be very very bad this is like I
just stability is so important and we
take it for granted so much ability is
so underrated political and social
stability like we need change we need to
change progressively and and actively
and continue the change making the world
a more fair and equitable place but we
also need not to have a civil war like
you vote like we do desperately need
political change and I completely agree
with you like the world is deeply unfair
and we must make it less unfair we must
make the world more just and that is
like the I think the calling of humans
yeah but we also cannot afford to have a
complete breakdown of the
medical stability of earth because if
that happens it would be devastating to
human populations and most devastating
to the most vulnerable human populations
so be nice to each other and also fight
fight fight fight fight to make your
government take climate change seriously
yeah I got another question for you anka
mom I'm glad we we've been all over the
place I mean this is this has been an
adventure I we're even are we yeah I am
rpm it's zero bright thirty this
question comes from garnet he writes
Dear John and Hank my boyfriend and I
are planning to become engaged this
winter we've already agreed to marry
each other but we want family therefore
the actual proposal it's a secret are we
engaged this engagement is like a secret
snake we've already have it but nobody
knows or it's like a secret fiddle
recital we know it will happen but it
hasn't happened yet those are two deep
deep cut dear Hank and John jokes Oh
Thank You garnet for listening so
closely to the pod please help us solve
this riddle of the schrödinger's
engagement but split [ __ ] garnet oh
that's another callback callback do not
a dear Hank and John Joe yeah alright
here's the thing Hank is this more of a
situation where you have made a
commitment to get so good at the violin
that you are going to have a violin
recital for your family and Surprise
them or is this more like a thing where
you already own something but you
haven't announced to the world that you
own it yeah is it a secret snicker is it
a secret violin recital right I think
it's a secret violin recital I agree
because and this is a general thing with
with proposals that like you it almost
seems like it's a proposal I'm making
this proposal and so on some level I
wanted to be a surprise but also I don't
want it to be a surprise because I don't
want you to be like alright I have you
know three seconds to decide whether or
not I want to spend the rest of my life
with you I want to have that
conversation in a number of times in a
number of ways and discuss a number of
different things before it's like here's
the the diamond right or not we're not
doing a sapphire from Montana is that
way you got
no I got my my great-grandmother's ring
oh you didn't get that one that's always
saving money mom offered she said she
said she came this dead woman came to my
mother in a dream and told her to give
me the ring so that's that I can't say
note of that and Hanks response was
thanks for saving me 500 bucks which is
what he would have spent on a ring um
anyway moving on yeah I don't think
you're engaged because I I think part of
being engaged maybe is it being known to
your family mm-hmm like to me that's
part of the process by the way I don't
think you have to get engaged I think
you can just get married if you want to
also the great thing about that is you
never have to say the word fiance never
god I hate that word so much it's I
don't like I'm fine I just hate I hated
using it I had a team this is my fiancee
Katherine I'm like I have to have this
intermediate word that I'm gonna use for
six months and if I say girlfriend
people are gonna get mad at me yeah or
just yeah it's an awkward and so say we
used to say partner yeah but even that
is it is it's awkward because they're
like so you're in business together
what are you saying oh but then it's
more like well are you married or not
married and yeah it's into a whole
conversation I have a new answer to this
question Hank I've thought about it more
and my new answer is that you are
engaged literally when you both agree
that you are engaged and not until then
okay of engagement in this next question
comes from Jennifer who asks dear Hank
and John if telescopes work using
mirrors does that mean it's possible the
outer space is full of vampires Jennifer
great question Jennifer a couple things
mm-hmm I don't know you feel about this
Hank but I don't think vampires are real
I don't think that you could just say
something like that as if it's known
because outer space could be full of
vampires it could be it could be it
could be I mean to be clear we don't
just we don't just detect space with
with mirrors there are other ways we do
it but the question is would would
vampires be detected but through any of
those means like are they are they sort
of the ambient temperature of bat of
space do they like block background
reading
I mean I don't really like the fact that
you can't see them in a mirror like it
makes me think that there's something
very weird about vampires on the scale
of like weird the way that dark matter
is weird like we don't understand how
that works like how could something be
visible in one like like something can't
be visible standing there but not when
the light happens to be reflected off a
mirror it doesn't make any sense so I'm
thinking vampires are dark matter it's a
theory I was gonna go in a different
direction with this question the thing
this question made me think of is how
incredibly hard it is to prove a
negative
like if somebody says you're a communist
and then you say well no I'm actually
not I'm not a communist and they're like
we'll prove it that becomes very
difficult right it becomes very
difficult to prove like that's one of
the great like political strategies of
the 2017 Twitter driven political
discourse is the you make a wild
accusation mm-hmm and then everyone's
like well no that doesn't make any sense
but then you can keep finding data that
makes it so that the accusation isn't
completely refuted so that it is not
right quite yet irrefutable and that is
a little bit like vampires in space so
when we see ourselves I would say when
we see ourselves in situations either
where we are making accusations or
looking into accusations consider the
possibility that it might be of vampires
in space question but like the thing
that you're trying to disprove or prove
is it a vampire's in space moment is my
question that's what I would ask you to
hold on to oh I'm Hank I'm very
discouraged about the political
discourse in the United States right now
I know that I've said that a few times
in the last year but I am I am more
discouraged that I have been at any
point I think ever in my whole life
it's very worrisome to me uh-huh
vampires in space I feel like we
occasionally I'll have this moment where
I'm like oh my lord
we are monkeys with guns like we have
been given a tool that we do not
understand yes and we do we have not
figured it out yet yes and it is
dangerous
yeah the social inner
is totally a monkeys with guns situation
we're like we don't even understand the
consequences of it so like we keep
pulling the trigger and things keep
dying and we keep being like why did
that happen like we don't understand
what the trigger does yet you know it's
not really monkeys with guns it's more
like ant eaters with guns or something
the guard markets with guns that's what
it is because like it's like you're you
don't like at least monkeys could make
they're like like a connection really
like I understand that this is a gun
right this and stuff they die oh man
Stubbs got stuff got real weird in here
what everything so weird everything
everything is worse now I'd understand
but it's like a gun where the sound of
firing the gun gives you a little
Russian dopamine little hit of dopamine
in the reward center of your brain and
because we're aardvarks with guns we're
like man I love that sound
you just keep firing the gun and you're
like god this sound is great there are
fewer aardvarks in the world right now
but I love this sound I want to keep
making it and then you're like man why
are my friends dying I love this sound
give me more of the sound now that I'm
lonelier because all my friends are dead
I need more of the sound I need it more
than ever
give me the sound hey this metaphor
sober oh my god Hank you have stumbled
upon a metaphor for the social Internet
that might just have changed my whole
life it might be that I have to get off
the internet because now I realize that
I'm just an aardvark with a gun you're
pulling the trigger
they don't have fingers they don't they
don't know how they're pulling the
trigger either we have no idea what
we're doing and with that noted let's
move on to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon okay John news from Mars is
great news
oh good on my cheeks hurt oh do too
smiling into the face of doom but mm-hmm
curiosity Rover's drill it drills into
some rocks and you can get like rock
powder and you can find out not just
what's on the surface of the rock but
also what's inside of the rock this is a
useful tool that broke it's hard to
drill on other planets and I think it's
something to do the stabilizer so the
drill itself is okay but the
that stabilizes it so that it can go in
and not get stuck broke and so they have
been working for a long time on how to
maybe get the drill to work despite the
fact that the drill doesn't work and
they are doing it they've figured out a
way they think and they're testing it
right now to drill on Mars again it's
been I think almost a year more than a
year that they haven't been able to
drill and they're basically using like
some parts of the rover that we're not
meant to be used to do this to like it
the get the drill bit to go in but have
it so that there's like they're
measuring the pressure so that it it's
not confused about about like sort of
its connection to the side of the rock
as it enters the rock and anything
pushing to the side of that could make
it so that the drill would get stuck and
then they just have to break the drill
bit and they would definitely not be
able to drill anything on Mars anymore
and that way that new drilling technique
is gonna allow them to start drilling on
Mars again see what's on the inside of
some new rocks now that they're on a
different part of the side of Mount
sharp they are sort of moved up the lake
bed some more and they can find out more
about this wonderful lake bed they've
been doing this well basically using a
like a version of curiosity that's here
on earth so it's basically one like just
a mock-up of the exact thing and they
can do a bunch of tests and I love
seeing like that scientists pictures
other scientists with the you know the
model curiosity on earth because you're
like that thing is freaking huge I
forget how huge it is minivan and then
and it also was like how did that
scientist get to Mars right because
you're used to seeing it on Mars but I
love it like they they have to go in and
look at the problems and think okay well
so how would I solve that problem if I
couldn't touch it how would I do with
this problem if it were millions of
miles away and had to fix itself yeah
yeah they did it
yeah but engineers engineers are amazing
speaking of amazing that's actually not
a very good transmission into the ASU
amazing is you know there's different
kinds of amazing things are amazingly
worrisome AFC Wimbledon after winning
two league games lost one to the lowest
team in the table which was very it's
very worrisome yeah and and at this
point AFC Wimbledon are not currently in
the relegation zone they are have 15
points after 15 games but they are only
one place away they are in 20th and
places 21 through 24 in Ligue 1 all go
down to Ligue 2 of more concern AFC
Wimbledon's leading striker Kwesi Appiah
upaya i don't know how to say his name i
apologize
has had a hamstring injury for a while
and it looks like he has had a setback
and is going to miss an additional
couple weeks knee largely the manager of
AFC Wimbledon said if we weren't
creating chances and our stats were low
then we would have real cause for
concern let me submit that we do have
real cause for concern as our stands are
I would argue low ish I mean 15 games
nine goals not great not great fewest
goals in the league not I would say our
stats are low ish but you know so how
long is this hamstring injury even
happening is this part of the reason why
there are a lot of goals or is like
you're like lead striker but he's never
scored a goal before he had a few games
and he didn't didn't score much but but
he only had a few games before he got
injured he the truth is that it you know
we are now one third of the way into the
season it is going to be a very it's
gonna be one of those years where it's
going to be difficult and like the
second season in a new league is is
usually harder than the first season and
it's gonna be hard to stay in league one
but I believe that AFC Wimbledon can do
it it's just instead of like rooting for
them to make the playoffs we're gonna be
rooting for them to narrowly avoid the
drop and that's gonna be the kind of
year it is alright I'm sorry John that's
okay we're gonna be we were just gonna
get points where we can find him Hank
just it's going to be okay don't panic
speaking of not panic
do you want to look at this picture of
aardvark fingers mm yeah oh
aardvarks could totally shoot a gun yeah
I mean those are those we'll put those
on the patreon patreon sighs dear Hank
and John if you want to get a good look
at aardvark fingers I'm crushing it on
the pronunciation today all right yeah
also if you go to patreon you can get
our semi-weekly short patron only
podcast this week in Ryan's this weekend
Ryan which I don't know if we're gonna
be able to do today hopefully yeah we're
gonna do it all right I'm ready I got a
Ryan all ready for it okay Hank what do
we learn today we learned that don't
chew on your friends things we learned
that Hank and John have many things
currently available from dftba.com
and also art Cisco tis my new book
Turtles all the way down you learned all
the things we also learned that you
should keep a lock of your child's hair
the first haircut but not every haircut
and of course we learned that the second
most embarrassing thing about hey is
that for about a year he had a fake fish
you did not learn the most embarrassing
thing about Hanks which probably is the
right call yes adoring the face that
Nick made I think when we talked I think
Nick's gonna keep that one in the vault
for if he ever needs just a raise just
needs a favor all right Hank thank you
for party with me and thanks to
everybody for listening this podcast is
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
sheridan Gibson our social media and
community manager is Victoria bon giorno
it's edited by Nicholas Jenkins who is
watching us Inuk he was there the whole
time yeah song giggling its thing our
music is by the great gunnarolla thank
you again for listening and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]